io
il deserto come il deserto vi fa paura
al deserto quando pensate al deserto
cosa vi viene in mente caldo sabbia
paura solitudine posso raccontarvi
deserto e dirvi che non è quello che si
immagina il deserto non fa paura il
deserto luogo che protegge avvolge in un
abbraccio posso dirvelo io che hanno
attraversati 5 più altri 2 è un luogo
che trasmette una grandissima energia
la mia storia nel deserto è iniziata nel
91 quando mio marito mi trovavo nel
deserto per tenere in diceva girare un
documentario per la televisione e ho
incontrato una carovana del sale erano
centinaia di cammelli decine di tuareg
che venivano da settimane di cammino nel
deserto ci sono sfilati davanti non si
sono fermati è l'unica cosa che ci hanno
chiesto camminando e stato un pacchetto
di fiammiferi
a quel punto mi si è accesa una
lampadina ho detto io questo luogo devo
conoscerlo
cosa c'è in quel deserto io voglio
sempre percorsi con le macchine con le
jeep esatto avere quello fatto a piedi
da sola entrare nel deserto un altro mio
marito detto l'anno prossimo mi unisco
una carovana di salemi a guardate tutto
sei matta l'anno successivo sono
riuscita a noi ma è una carovana del
sale sono partita da sola con 17 tua
ricche e 200 cammelli ed è stata
un'esperienza direi difficilissima
terribile forse per la prima volta mi
trovavo davanti deserto vero quello
forte quello che non conoscevo questi
uomini non mi hanno aiutata però mi
hanno rispettata soprattutto mi hanno
insegnato i due aree che sono stati dei
grandi maestri di vita mi hanno
insegnato a conoscere deserto nella sua
essenzialità mi hanno insegnato ad
amarlo che mi hanno insegnato a
rispettarlo
ho terminato quell'impresa sfinita
credevo veramente di non arrivare alla
fine temperature che sfioravano i 50
gradi si camminava dall'alba a notte
fonda
a parte in piedi a parte dorso di
cammello ma soprattutto da questa grande
fatica che non avevo dentro la sera mi
chiudevo nella mia tendina isolata dal
campo dei tuareg e urlava urlavo come
stessa
da una parte c'era la carlà che conosco
quella che vi ha deciso di fare
l'impresa di andare avanti
dall'altra c'è lo era sconosciuta che mi
diceva tu non ce la farai mai allora io
lottavo con lei è una lotta continua
certo punto vinto io ho vinto io perché
ce l'ho fatta dagli partita tutta la
storia dei deserti 94 entra fa parte del
team sector no limits attraverso l'albo
salato in bolina salar di uyuni e poi a
seguire il calari e quindi che i due
grandi deserti cinese è australiano sono
state tutte imprese tutti i record però
la cosa principale non è mai stata per
me record cioè arrivare dall'altra parte
non voleva dimostrare a nessuno che la
più brava la più forte
semplicemente che avevo realizzato un
sogno perché per me i deserti sono stati
tutti dei grandi sogni è la cosa più
bella tra detti meglio la vita è quella
di realizzare i propri sogni
io ho avuto questa grande fortuna di
vivere questi sogni quindi c'è tanto
lavoro dietro le imprese e immaginatevi
che ognuna richiede circa due anni tre
anni di lavoro intenso che vuol dire
preparazione fisica sedute in palestra
quotidiane seguita da preparatori
atletici allenatori seguita da medici di
medicina dello sport che dovevano
mettere appunto l'alimentazione seguita
da sforzo che dovevano creare materiali
apposta perché dovevo portare tutto
quanto mi serviva per sopravvivere in un
deserto sulle spalle
voleva dire avere carichi di 25 chili
non è preso 53 mi vedete sono magrina
minuti eppure ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta perché
perché credevo nel mio sogno perché
avevo tanta passione e soprattutto è un
obiettivo da raggiungere ma per arrivare
a quell'obiettivo
la cosa fondamentale questa me l'ha
insegnato al deserto era quello di
trovare un equilibrio un equilibrio fra
me stessa e lui l'idea senato il deserto
non l'ho mai sfidato non sono mai
entrato in un deserto dicendo devo
vincere ti devo farcela
tu sei il mio nemico e io devo superare
te no non si affronta così un deserto un
ambiente naturale talmente forte
talmente in pieno di energia che aveva
perso hai perso subito
l'unica cosa per entrare in un deserto e
avere la speranza di arrivare dall'altra
parte l'ho capito grazie forse anche tu
aree che di quella prima impresa era
quello di entrare a testa bassa e dire
per favore aiutami aiutami andare avanti
aiutami a passare i primi tre giorni
sono i peggiori sono i giorni della
ricerca dell'equilibrio i giorni qui qui
dicevo appunto ci sono queste due
personalità le due carnet che si
scontrano male piedi le piaghe dolore
alla schiena
vuol dire che devo fermarmi o posso
continuare andare avanti
vuol dire spingere avanti i propri
limiti o arrendersi dire non posso
andare oltre
ebbene io posso dirvi una cosa che dopo
5 deserti quelle che avete visto più
altri due traversate in seguito il mio
limite vero non l'ho mai incontrato
ancora sono sempre riuscito a spostarlo
avanti sempre un poco di più il momento
in questo stata più vicina ad
abbandonare quindi a riconoscere un
limite è stato nel deserto del kalahari
avevo deciso di attraversare questo
deserto come non fanno i boscimani nel
quindi sono entrata in una piccola
comunità di boscimani con loro sono
stata tre giorni e poi con uno di loro
case
ho attraversato il ta clima il deserto
del kalahari come lo fanno loro
quando si spostano per trasferimenti
quindi
senza usare nessun tipo di integratore
senza usare cibo tradizionale quello che
noi siamo abituati e partendo solo con 7
litri di acqua e una manciata di bilton
carne secca quella che loro usano
normalmente
inutile nascondere che è stata
un'impresa veramente molto difficile mio
fisico si stava mangiando i miei muscoli
si stavano consumando non aveva uno
strumento la figura di case non era
quella di guida ma semplicemente lui
doveva mostrarmi cosa c'era in quel
deserto di commestibile cosa avrei
potuto mangiare c'era pochissimo radici
bacche qualche meloncino selvatico delle
resine attaccate le piante cose che
comunque davano ha pochissima energia ma
il grosso problema è stata l'acqua dopo
quei 7 litri non trovavamo più acqua mi
sono resa conto che la mia sete era la
sua sete non è vero che loro sono
abituati a non bere sono come noi a quel
punto detto se domani a mezzogiorno non
si trova dell'acqua mi fermo non posso
morire di sete che ad esempio darei io
alla mia famiglia ai giovani e tutti a
chi mi sta seguendo
sembra strano il giorno dopo prima di
mezzogiorno
siamo arrivati in un piccolo villaggio
boscimane e diceva l'acqua e ci hanno
dato l'acqua ecco questo mi ha fatto
pensare in qualche modo il deserto ma
abbia voluto aiutare e credo che questo
sia sempre successo io si può che la
sete è qualcosa di terrificante non la
auguro al peggiore dei miei nemici
ho scoperto che con la mente si può
governare e controllare la fame la
fatica il dolore la sete no ma siete fa
partire il cervello davanti all'assenza
non si ragiona più
ebbene con la volta ho conosciuto vero
limite è anche quella volta si è
spostato grazie a lui al deserto che mi
ha aiutato devo dire che forse quando
sono entrati in un deserto non me ne
rendevo conto
ma quello che è successo in realtà è
stata la scoperta delle proprie emozioni
la scoperta di se stessi o nel deserto
ho capito chi sono chi sono io carla
perrotti dove volevo andare cosa volevo
fare nella mia vita e questo credo che
sia un'opportunità che tutti noi abbiamo
quella di metterci in gioco di
confrontarci di capire chi siamo e dove
vogliamo andare
dove vogliamo andare non è impossibile
credetemi nulla impossibile
io l'ho e mezzo quando avevo le piaghe
nei piedi
ho immaginato di camminare sollevata
dalla sabbia per non sentire il dolore e
paradossalmente queste piaghe stavano
guarendo nonostante continuare a
camminare coi miei venticinque chili
sulle spalle nella sabbia
il nostro cervello ha un potenziale
impressionante vi assicuro che tutto è
possibile
qualsiasi cosa possiamo fare noi però
dobbiamo volerlo
dobbiamo crederci assolutamente e avere
molto chiaro l'obiettivo il cambiamento
da quanto mi riguarda è stato duplice la
prima volta quando ha incontrato al
deserto quando mai cambiato la vita
la seconda volta quando ho realizzato
sogno ho chiuso ciclo deserto per
continente e da lì mi sono detta io
questo patrimonio incredibile che sono
riuscita ad avere come regalo dal
deserto perché è stato un regalo lo
considero tale
ecco questo patrimonio non posso tenerlo
solo per me
l'egoismo che aveva sempre
contraddistinto le mie imprese perché io
nei deserti avevo messo tutto io deserto
l'ho amato in maniera impressionante
disperata dopo quei primi tre giorni in
cui dovevo cercare l'equilibrio e
raggiungevo l'equilibrio allora deserto
diventava un alleato un amico un amore
mi godevo le mie imprese
andavo anche senza fatica senza più
pensare e avere angoscia una parte
quella dell'acqua che è sempre comunque
l'angoscia e quindi mi sono detta ma
perché questo grande patrimonio che ho
avuto la possibilità di conoscere e di
avere da lui non lo metto al servizio
degli altri è giusto che anche altre
persone godano di questo quindi nel 2008
attraversato il deserto egiziano
accompagnando fabio pasinetti un atleta
ceco non vedente di bergamo e ho
realizzato il suo sogno
fabio desiderava con tutto se stesso
conosce il deserto e quando abbiamo
terminata la nostra impresa insieme due
settimane si è meglio la sua guida ai
suoi occhi fare toccarli una cosa del
genere non lo immaginavo io quel
silenzio del deserto nella mia vita non
ho mai più sentito mi ha cambiato la
vita e la seconda esperienza
a seguito di questo è stato quello di
desert therapy un progetto con il quale
sto accompagnando piccoli gruppi di
persone normalissime come voi come tutti
a conoscere il deserto li accompagna per
mano si cammina a piedi e si gode di
questa meraviglia e io posso garantirvi
che tutte le persone che sono entrate
nel deserto ma tutte indistintamente
quando sono uscita mi hanno detto questo
luogo mi ha cambiato
ecco questo è il deserto
quindi non è un luogo da temere un luogo
che va conosciuto incontrato o dico
sempre una volta nella vita
andate in un deserto mi insegnerà a
superare i vostri deserti piccoli e
grandi deserti quotidiani perché
ciascuna di noi ha dei deserti tutti i
giorni da attraversare
spero tanto che la mia esperienza possa
in qualche modo aiutare gli altri a
superare i pochi deserti buon deserto a
tutti